من القاهره الفنانه غنوه محمود اهلا بك يا
غنوه معنا في مساء العربيه رمضان كريم
غنوه اسمعيني هلا يا غنوه
ايه عم بسمع اهلا وسهلا فيك ورمضان كريم
وهل هي التجربه الكوميديه الاولى لك
مزبوط هي التجربه الاولى
بصراحه هو المشكل ما كان انه بشكل شخصي
معه كان عم بيهدي مشكل فحرام بصراحه الظلم
بهذا الموضوع انه هو صار مشكله مع ناس ولو
ما تدخلوا وهيك فك المشكله ما كانت انحلت
بصراحه لانه كان كان صار مشكله كتير كبيره
على الست وكلنا كنا هيك خفنا وتوترنا وكنا
راح نمشي وفعلا هو اللي هدى الموضوع
ولو ما هيك كان رد فعله شوي قاسي على بعض
الناس يمكن ما كان فك المشكل بالعكس وحتى
صار في تراضي وانبسطوا كثير رجعوا تصالحوا
بسببه فبالعكس نحن يعني بسبب ورجع صار تم
الصلح فهذا الشيء كان كتير نحنا بس انه
نفهم بطريقه غلط يمكن على السوشيال ميديا
لانه تسرب مقطع جزء كثير صغير من اللي صار
طيب غنوه كان عندك مشاركه مختلفه تماما
هذه المره في مسلسل واخيرا بعيد عن
الكوميديا حدثينا اكثر عنها
بمسلسل واخيرا اخذت هيك لعبت دور شوي فيه
شر مع انه ما بيشبهني ابدا بس دايما يمكن
انه بتضطر تلعب الدور بطريقه يعني محترفه
فهيك الناس شويه يعني
هلا بطالبوني بادوار الشر لانه حبوني كثير
بالدور الشر بس بنفس الوقت يعني عرفتي هيك
كان في هجوم بالاول انه لا ليش هالقد كنت
صعبه وشريره بس الدور تطلب بس كمان النجمه
الكبيره
كمان فخر لبنان لانه فعلا محبوبه بشكل
كثير كبير ودائما بتقدم اعمال حلوه كتير
وانت كمان يا غنوه كسبتي قلوب الجماهير
كمان غنوه كمان قلتي في تصريحات سابقه انه
ارفض تسليق الضوء على المواضيع المستفزه
حول البنت اللبنانيه بطريقه معينه انه شو
قصدتي بهالتصريح
بصراحه انه اكثر الادوار اللي كانت تنعرض
لي اول ما جيت على مصر كتير فيها الاحداث
بتصب على الجمال وكثير هيك بيركزوا على
موضوع انه حلوه ملفته مغريه فانا كنت ضد
هذا الموضوع لانه فعلا نحن انه بلبنان
كثير منحب نشتغل على تفاصيل الشخصيه
كتمثيل واداء فانا ضد انه بس نركز على
الجمال ودائما كانوا يفكروا انه لا
الممثله اللبنانيه هي شكل فانا كنت دايما
انه ما بدي اثبت هذا الموضوع فكانت ارفض
هذه الادوار وكانت كثير بصراحه تنعرض علي
ادوار يعني تستفزني انه ليه دايما نحنا
انه اذا لبنانيه يعني يعني لا بالعكس
وقدرت غير هذا النظره عشان هيك دائما بقول
انه هذه المواضيع بحب يكون فيه بحب يكون
في موضوع في في دور حلو يتقدم يستفيد منه
الناس ان كان مسلي او مثلا مفيد
كمشاهد يعني بس انه بس هيك كشكل انا ضد
الفكره شكرا جزيلا لك غنوه محمود واهلا
وسهلا فيك في مساء العربيه اليوم شكرا